hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
so first Black Panther reactions are out
people and spoiler alert
I hear it's an okay movie maybe lower
actually three guys we wanted to give a
shout out today to today's video
sponsors Stardust at people over at
Stardust we do 30-second reactions for
any film TV show or trailer I'm sure you
guys the first talked plenty about them
and the reason why is because we use it
often over a hundred twenty posts over
there at our Stardust app there's a lot
of huge youtubers people much bigger
than ourselves using the app right now
but if we're the first ones to tell you
about it down the app and follow us
first let's do a reaction to people's
reactions and then people will react on
their own to our reactions so jealous
had a couple homies at the premiere
really yeah and they said it might be
their one of their favorite that's what
a lot of Stephen Weintraub from Collider
says Marvel does it again with black
panther very impressed with a story and
filmmaker Michael B Jordan absolutely
kills it as the villain is the best one
since Loki that's great that's great
deer also Dana Guerrera kicks so much
ass Dana go Rara how you say I think
it's Danai gurira deny Agera Michelle
kicks so much ass and I loved every
second of it going to make serious
dollar signs cool so Michael B Jordan
that's just one opinion right now let's
all right okay has more let's find
Steven Weintraub second opinion
something else I loved about Black
Panther is Ryan Coogler found an organic
way to talk about important real world
issues without it feeling preachy or
fake yeah it's hard to do in any movie
but to make it work in a big Marvel
movie is even more impressive that's
really cool funny you mention one thing
but though he's talking about Michael B
Jordan being one of the best villains as
best villain since Loki and that's
something I've been talking about in the
trailers I feel like because it's Ryan
Coogler he's gonna make sure his homeboy
Michael B Jordan who's gonna kick major
ass in this movie I was excited for the
casting of Danai I wasn't really
expecting like scene-stealer comments
about her it's more like oh cool casting
comments that's what I was expecting
more out of her
there's a huge cast here with a bunch of
great actors and I couldn't expect
everyone to be standout but to hear that
she's standing out as cool and I usually
trust Stephen Weintraub's opinion more
importantly talking about real-world
issues without feeling preachy or fake
in a Marvel movie that is impressive
when you do that on a big blockbuster
scope with something in the MCU that is
especially impressive so hopefully I
walk out feeling the same way yeah I
hope so too and for me personally as a
movie goer that's something that I feel
like these movies could do a lot better
at and could do a lot more of you know
and could give them better roots to
stick around if we're talking about that
bubble not bursting you know stuff like
this inspires faith for me you know
Marvel is kind of known especially in
their mid and you know continuing phases
for bringing in new genres as a way to
update their stuff but I really like
that they're leading with culture for
black pants yeah all right here we go
Kristian harloff the harloff Kubler does
it again three for three
hey the rule of three three that's what
John and I always say is a director
needs three directors and actors need
three movies to establish for sure that
they are here to stay and craft services
people yes
Black Panther is thrilling emotional and
has one of the best-built
hey that's that's two confirmations
right there best bill is an MCU every
character has a purpose and it's a pure
ride from start to finish
great movie awesome exact what's getting
me really excited is Michael B Jordan
being hailed and once again no one's
mentioned chap we'll just expect
chadwick boseman he kill it I think what
people are talking about it was
surprises of the film right now and I
feel like at this point we would be kind
of astonished if the lead didn't do a
good job
yeah it's higher stakes for Marvel right
now for the villain to be good yeah and
in civil war when he when he appeared
everyone was like Black Panther stole
the show yeah travell Anderson Black
Panther is a love letter about blackness
to a world that often ghettoize is it
without realizing that it is on
lack backs that this planet revolves
well it's a kind of a tongue twister
that this world's livelihood is in our
blood damn hell yeah oh now we're
getting that you know one thing you were
talking about is you're really hoping
that we would get a big sense of culture
I imagine that when they're talking
about real world issues and stuff this
is part of what travell Anderson is
touching on here like he says a
love-letter about blackness not even
just I you know I haven't seen it but I
would imagine not even just about the
struggles and things like that but just
about you know the richness of the
history I would imagine not that it's
gonna be a history project but I like
hearing things like that a love-letter
about black is a nice thing because it
seems like they are embracing you know
and let us be authentic and there's a
lot more of that in the spectrum lately
like we are embracing this a lot more
and not ghettoizing it as our only means
of exploring it so yeah Helia Rebekah
Theodora become the production does Oh
first talk bone the production is and
the production design by Hannah beech
ler is so lovely and the cinematographer
Rachel Morrison Oh two women whoo by far
the best-looking himseif them that's
exciting to hear nice because when I saw
the movie clip with Jared - one thing
that we were talking about was the
production design of cinematography
standing it's specific and one thing the
MCU tends to get crap on is that the
music and the cinematography kind of
looks similar so to hear that
that's a standout is really really
intriguing to me and she also says in
the representation of black women a
black panther made me feel seen seen in
a way other superhero movies have not
done well awesome
so black people women this feels like
Hollywood's great awakening over the
past couple of years of going oh we just
cast everybody yeah I'm just gonna put
women in roles and I'm gonna put people
of color in roles and we're not just
gonna like default to white dude what's
cool about this is it doesn't even have
from just these few responses I don't
get the impression that it has any of
those syndromes from superhero origin
movie I know he was introduced in civil
war it's like the villains great the
production is great and the rest of the
cast is like everyone's talking about
everything around black panther
the elements of a movie should go to
support you know the core of it you know
it doesn't affect me the same yeah cuz
I'm a white dude so I've been
represented forever but even just for me
to see it and to see it in motion into
your brain catches those like this
shouldn't be extraordinary and yet it
feels that way cuz you're seeing it
you're like oh yeah this must be amazing
for people to finally see their
likenesses on screen gen Yamato
Yamato Yamato your mother what's your
motto like Panther is incredible kinetic
purposeful a superhero movie about why
representation and identity matters hell
yeah tragic it is when those things are
denied of people the first MC you about
something real Michael B Jordans kill
monger had me weeping and he's the
villain that's cool that's real a
villain we can real that is truly
three-dimensional that sounds awesome to
me man Wow this might be the ultimate
Marvel movie perfect one to take that
step with I mean is good timing for this
movie too yeah that idea the first MCU
movie about something real excites me
because you know I'm all for escapism
and fantasy in in its place and in its
doses I'm excited to see them stepping
up nice so way to the content Jaime is
February 16 2018 geo hidari coker black
panther is essential I like that I just
doubt right there it's essential okay
you know so many times you see movies
that are just throwaways now incredible
revolutionary woke fun I can't stop
thinking about it the cooler ization
them all the universe is exhilarating
please don't let him do any other movies
down that response always makes me laugh
like whenever somebody doesn't good one
everyone's like
varieties good for you Kate air blonde
says Black Panther feels like the actual
start of a new phase for Marvel oh
that's cool not only because it exists
so well in its own terms but because it
feels so new and timely through both its
storytelling the very people the story's
about and those who get to tell it
wonderful Wow everything from in front
of the camera and behind the camera
seems to be such an important part of it
and for her to be saying that it's a new
phase of Marvel also gets me excited
because one thing I'm getting from
lobbies comments is this is distinct and
a lot of times in the over fluctuation
of Marvel movies like three a year it's
easy to kind of forget what makes
certain ones feel distinct though you
can logically pinpoint them the feeling
to just walk away if you're not repeat
viewing it I feel like Black Panther is
probably gonna be that film that you can
just look back on and your feelings were
like yeah I remember that yeah I mean
even the advertising has felt distinct
amid the other Marvel trailers we won't
have Mike Ryan Black Panther is not
screwing around by far the most
political Marvel chapter to the point I
had to remind myself that this is a
Marvel movie Black Panthers movie with a
lot to say
also Michael B Jordan damn Michael B
Jordan stealing the show on this movie
man I'm so excited for him he's the most
talked about thing yeah characters under
the characters yeah on these early
reactions everyone's like kill ma Peters
Curtis Coretta Black Panther looks feels
and sounds unlike any Marvel film to
date a visual feast
Lokhande is amazingly realized the
antagonist actually has an arc with
emotional motivations Marvel's most
political movie so there's a common
thread here it's political it's
essential Michael B Jordan common thing
I've been seeing on all these it's like
it terms of visuals like we all expect
them to look good these are the things
yeah technical prowess that just comes
with the territory of Marvel but yeah
this seems like a step in a new
direction or new caliber anyway okay
this I just did a quick read of this one
German less here this is the exact these
are my exact kind of movies that I love
Black Panther is epic on the outside but
powerful and intimate on the inside it
feels totally different from the rest of
the MCU in the best possible ways that's
my exact kind of movie
like big and epic butts so important and
meaningful at its core yeah I feel like
that's the most responsible use of
spectacle too you know when you can wrap
up something that is meaningful inside
something that is exciting oh it's kind
of a kind of a negative one here yeah
it's just one minor complaint never mind
if i graph it it's like a Marvel movie
but better the action is predictably
awful I'm surprised to hear that but
this is the first time see you film that
has an actual sense of identity in
history and musicality musicality is
makanda is a live whole cast is great
but the woman in the war rhinos steal
the show it seems like the scene
stealers of the NIE and Michael hell
yeah dude yeah predictably awful action
though huh means well the only the only
meaning in a bad wig I sounds like a bad
thing I don't know what exactly he means
the one thing I guess I could maybe
latch on to is while I was watching the
trailer I was wondering to myself is
some of the action maybe some of the
like city-based action gonna feel like
kind of shoehorned into a movie that
doesn't necessarily require that much of
it but I don't know oh [ __ ] speed round
of famous people talking here Tessa
Thompson Valkyrie yourself Black Panther
my goodness I wish I was in this movie
to mail Nanjiani Black Panther so very
good I cheered and laughed and pumped my
fist I've never seen a superhero movie
like it everybody involved with it
deserves a medal and a high-five oh I
love them famous people like stuff James
Gunn extraordinary work by Ryan Coogler
and company Wakanda forever baby yeah
paid and read ant-man director here
Black Panther is fantastic beautiful
soulful thoughtful and of the moment
Ryan Coogler knows what he's doing long
live - chocolate I know more often than
not when you do like these earlier
responses they're usually very positive
even if it's like a movie that comes out
because you're normally only allowed to
say the positive things in terms of the
embargoes and all those all that stuff
with the praise and the respect I have
for a lot of the names I read off of
here I highly doubt I'm gonna walk away
disagreeing with these people man this
seems like it's gonna be a
Niq MCU film and everything we've been
thinking that it'll be like the one
thing I actually wasn't expecting is all
the stuff about how political it is and
how powerful moving all that stuff is I
thought there'd be cool themes to really
touch on but I wasn't expecting like
this is an essential piece and this is
an important MCU film and you will be
unique and you be distinct those
elements are getting me excited in the
confirmation from so many people about
Michael B Jordan has got to be really
jacked yeah most definitely I mean those
weren't things I was expecting
necessarily to hear about this movie and
that's just how I kind of approached
these types of films I'm not expecting
deep political discourse behind but to
hear that they are you know putting more
of that into this movie is really
awesome I mean I've they're they're
really capitalizing on their moment much
the same way Wonder Woman did by kind of
making that more than it had to be or
more than I thought it was gonna be
these early responses are making me
champ the bit for February 16 alright
guys well hey we got our Black Panther
tickets already do you guys got your
highest priests whole ticket history
alright you guys can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell to get notified every time one of
our videos is up keep a lookout for when
we have our Black Panther movie review
out probably do a spoiler talk on it as
well looks like we'll have to make sure
to download and follow us on the
Stardust app people at the real rejects
see over there